Daniel: All right.
And on to the last session of the first
interval.
Greetings, Nynke!
Greetings.
Nynke: Hello.
Good morning.
Daniel: Yes, good morning.
How goes it?
Nynke: Yeah, I'm doing fine, thanks.
Daniel: Would you like to present and
then we'll discuss?
Nynke: Yes, that sounds like a good idea.
.
Great.
Let's see.
Just going to share my screenplay.
Yes.
Can you see the presentation?
Daniel: Not yet.
Nynke: Okay.
See flex.
Daniel: Yes.
Looks perfect.
Nynke: Okay, great.
Yeah.
Should I just start?
Daniel: Yeah, go for as long as you want,
and then anyone can ask questions in the
live chat, and I'll write down some
things, too.
Thank you.
Nynke: Okay, great.
Yeah.
So my presentation today will be on
advances in machine theory of mind and
theory of mind.
Sophistication I'm currently a student at
the University of Amsterdam and finishing
my master's thesis on this topic.
And I'll be giving a broad overview of
current machine theory of mind and an
idea or concept for an active inference
approach based on previous work related
to active inference theory of mind.
So to start okay, sorry.
So for a global overview, we'll start
with giving a short basic definition of
what theory of mind is and how it's been
used.
Then I'll give you a global overview of
current approaches to designing machine
theory of mind, including evasion
approaches, approaches using Biphysical
models, et cetera.
Then I'll zoom into active inference
models of theory of mind and social
intelligence and collective intelligence
more broadly.
And I'll get into the issue of theory of
mind.
Sophistication, which is basically the
depth of recursivity of beliefs that you
can have about another person's mental
states and their thoughts or beliefs or
goals about you.
And then we'll get into the issue of how
to implement recursive beliefs.
And as an example, we'll discuss Bayesian
theory of mind with K levels of depth.
And then we'll get into the more specific
paradigm that I'm using right now to
build a theory of mind model, which is
based on a very simple model of the
matching panning paradigm.
So we'll talk a little bit about that,
and then we'll get into the model itself
and current ideas for implementing theory
of mind sophistication using active
inference.
So first of all, what is theory of mind?
Theory of mind has been introduced by the
very famous paper by Primac and Woodcherf
in 1978, I think it was called does the
Chimpanzee Have a Theory of Mind?
And they define theory of mind as the
ability to impute mental states to
himself and others as a system of
inferences.
And they say system of inferences of this
kind is properly viewed as a theory,
first, because such states are not
directly observable, and second, because
the system can be used to make
predictions specifically about the
behavior of other organisms.
And I think there's already a lot in this
definition.
And a lot of authors looking at theory of
mind right now still use the same view of
theory of mind as a theory, a structured
theory of different kinds of mental
states such as goals, beliefs and desires
that facilitate the prediction of
observable behavior in other agents such
as facial expressions, movement or speech.
.
And I find it very interesting how much
this aligns with maybe a predictive
processing view of social cognition, but
also how weird it is that this theory,
theory of theory of mind is still so
widespread in the theory of mind
literature, modeling literature.
So there's been some discussion on
whether you can properly regard theory of
mind as a theory and if so, what kind of
theory it is.
So within the philosophy of mind, there's
been basically two mainstreams or main
perspectives on theory of mind.
According to the classic theory, theory
of Tom, theory of mind is a causal theory
of how these internal mental states
generate other agents'behaviors.
So it's the same kind of view that we
just saw.
And then the opposite side is called
simulation theory of theory of mind,
which posits that we use the same kind of
cognitive and neurological resources for
understanding and predicting other agents
as those that we use for understanding
the self.
And simulation theory can also take on
different forms.
The sun is coming up next to them.
So that's why I'm based in light at the
moment.
But basically there are lots of versions
of this.
Some posit that we use the same kind of
action prediction mechanisms for
ourselves as for others.
And there is this new version of
simulation theory that Gordon proposes in
2021 which very broadly says that we have
the same kind of theory for other agents
for ourselves.
So there's this general theory for what
it means to be an agent that is refined
at different stages to facilitate context
sensitive predictions in social
interactions.
So this is also interesting to look at
when you model theory of mind, what you
think theory of mind is and how it is
specifically implemented.
So why would we be interested in creating
computational models of theory of mind?
So I think there are three important
reasons why this is very relevant at the
moment.
First of all, there is a technical reason
or the reason of technological
advancement.
There's been some proposals that argue
for the development of artificial social
intelligence.
Oh wait, yes.
So the technical reason for developing
computational models of theory of mind is
to improve artificial social intelligence,
, especially as we start to live in a
world in which research on human AI
interaction becomes more relevant.
And that's been this paper Bob Williams,
for example, that's argued that improving
artificial social intelligence is needed
for successful AI human cooperation and
it could improve communication, trust and
maybe also value alignment.
By utilizing theory of mind for value
alignment.
For example, there is a very strong
foundational reason to study social
cognition generally and the evolution of
social cognition through in silica
hypothesis testing and clarifying the
conceptual boundaries of theory of mind.
One great example for this is research by
Devane ETL, which used a computational
model of recursive theory of mind
compared to alternative models to study
different cognitive strategies in non
human primates.
And they find no evidence for the
hypothesis that theory of mind
sophistication involved with an increase
in herd size, but they do find a
correlation with, for example, neocortex
ratio.
So in this way, theory of mind models can
give us some insight into the evolution
of social cognition.
On the clinical side, theory of mind
models can be used to understand relevant
social variations in clinical populations,
, for example, through computational
phenotyping and diagnostics and by
studying social behavior in groups that
have some difficulty with social
interactions.
And groups that show some kind of
variation in social cognition, such as
people with autism spectrum, people in
the autistic spectrum, people with ADHD
or schizophrenia.
So I hope that with some of these reasons,
, I convinced you that modeling theory of
mind is very relevant at the moment.
And there have been a lot of people
already on this.
And I've created this very global
overview of some approaches that are
representative or some models that are
representative of their more general
approaches.
There's this brain Tom model which aims
to basically build up clear mind
abilities and abilities facilitating
social interaction from the bottom up
using Biphysical models of neural firings.
.
That's why I've placed it on the dynamic
scale.
So I've tried to align these modeling
approaches along the axes of how they
treat time, how broad their description
is from the individual level to maybe
describing more broader social and
cultural processes and along the level of
description from the molecular
biophysical to the behavioral.
And one thing you can see is that there
is a lot of work based on invasion
inference and active inference that moves
along that has relevant ties to the
molecular and neurobiological level but
moves along the lines of making
behavioral and cognitive predictions.
And there are very little models that
really also formalize the concrete
implementation of theory of mind.
And there is also, I think, this need for
connecting this dynamic implementational
level to individual level social
cognition and putting that in the context
of social interaction more generally.
So some of the representational
approaches that I selected are the TOMNET,
, which basically uses neural network
embeddings to train reinforcement
learning agents.
We have Ktom, which is a Bayesian
recursive model which I'll come back to
later, some or theory of mind with self
other modeling uses multiagent
reinforcement learning with goal
inference.
And we have the more theoretical active
inference model of implicit cultural
learning called thinking through other
minds, which could be seen as an
alternative or a redefinition of theory
of mind.
Okay, so to sum up, we have this stream
of biophysical models, most notably Brain
Tom, which was developed by Zhao et al.
And its strengths are its neurobiological
plausibility at making dynamic
predictions about neural activation in
populations that are associated with
theory of mind abilities and its
weaknesses is that it's quite
computational and costly and it's
probably difficult to implement in an
interactional setting.
There are some deep learning models such
as Tomnets by Rabinovitz and Self other
modeling which I just mentioned that are
also quite neurobiologically plausible
and also make some dynamic predictions.
But there is this strong danger of
shortcuts, which has been addressed in
deep learning models, that the task might
not be solved by learning the relevant
ability of being able to infer another
agent's goals or beliefs, but just by
learning simple lower level associations
between, for example, the perspective or
how another agent stands and where, for
example, a food reward would be.
So there are a lot of ways to solve the
task and there's this finding that deep
learning models sometimes use these kinds
of shortcuts so that's something that's
needed to be addressed.
Then there are some Bayesian belief based
models such as K Tom for Recursive theory
of Mind and Beijing Tom which was
originally developed by Baker et al.
In 2011 and its strengths are that it's
quite efficient, it's very easy to
interpret and its weaknesses are that the
road to the implementational level is
longer and it requires many priors and
there's this question about whether it's
scalable because of the prior
specifications that you have to give.
Okay, so as one of the I think the
interesting newer developments on a
theory of mind wait, yes.
Is Hierarchical active Inference for
collaborative agents which has been
recently published and Haika is based on
the Asian theory of mine by Baker et al.
But it adds this formalization of belief
resonance which is the incorporation of
beliefs about another's intentions with
top down predictions and this influence
of these other agents beliefs are
modulated by susceptibility parameter
which controls this influence.
And what I find I think it's important to
note here that they use an approach based
on active inference but they don't use
the free energy principle for example.
So they do couple perception and action
but just in a different way using a karma
filter.
So the way they formalize this is
slightly different but I think the
overall structure can still be informing
or inspiring for active inference methods.
.
So what is interesting about their
simulation results is that they show that
agent that there is some emergent
collaboration on tasks for low values of
the susceptibility parameter without any
explicit planning or communication needed.
.
And this means that they improve upon the
original Bayesian model, which explored
different sort of overall plans for all
of the agents, which means that an agent
employing Bayesian Tom would need to
reason about the roles of all of the
other agents, which was very costly.
And the authors wanted to improve on that
to model maybe on the fly coordination,
which is more spontaneous and takes less
time.
And they also show that incorporating
belief resonance has a very positive
effect in scenarios in which there's
unbalanced information.
They did this simulation, the overcooked
domain in which agents have to
collaborate on different cooking tasks
and the goal is basically the order, the
cooking order.
And then the intention would be any kind
of action that has to do with completing
the order.
And they show that incorporating the leaf
resonance seems to be especially useful
in situations with unbalanced information
which, for example, one agent knows the
order and the other doesn't.
And these agents develop some kind of
leader follower dynamic in which one is
more susceptible to the other agent's
intentions and one agent attends more to
the evidence from the environment.
And this also aligns with what we know
about your mind mainly being employed in
situations in which there is some
asymmetry in what the agents know about
the environment.
So I thought that was very insightful.
Okay, so I'm going to go into some active
inference approaches that I think are
relevant for developing active inference
theory of mind.
First of all, there's this very broad
proposal on inculturation and non
development thinking for other minds, a
variational approach to cognition and
culture, which we'll go into a little bit.
.
We'll go into Castle and HAF's paper on
ideas for spreading a free energy
proposal for cumulative cultural dynamics.
.
We'll go into Kaufman et al's.
Model on collective intelligence and
finally also the proposal by Mutusis et
al.
On Beijing inferences about the self and
others.
Okay, so first of all, I am starting with
beta inference about the self and others
because it gives a very sort of broad
introduction to, I think, predictive
social cognition.
And that's also why I've added this
figure on the right that is from the Tam
Thoughts and paper in 2018, which
explores the predictive social brain and
what kind of features seem to be relevant
for categorizing and understanding others
behaviors.
Some figure on the right, you see that
there is this space, this trade space,
which is ordered by power, sociality and
balance, and that constraints the state
space which seems to be ordered by
rationality, social impact and balance.
Of course, these are just correlations,
but these futures seem to be most
predictive of what they're seeing in the
brain.
And you can see that there is this sort
of basically a very strong top down
constraint of the possibility space in
which you interpret other people's
actions.
And you can also see that based on
another agent's actions, you learn
something about where they fall within
that space in a given context and also
where they fall in that trade space.
What kind of so at the same time, you
might have already have some priorities
on what kind of a person this is, but you'
're also learning about it.
You might also have some priors on how
someone behaves when they're mad, for
example, or when they're sociable versus
unsociable.
And all these kinds of priors informative
priors.
They inform your predictions in the
context, and they make this task much
more manageable of predicting other
people's behaviors on the fly.
And I think that links very well back to
Mutuses proposal, which is basically that
inferences about the self and others at
different timescales facilitates
interpersonal minimization of surprise
and thereby optimal social decision
making.
And these self and other representations
that facilitate personal minimization of
surprise could be seen as representations
that inform our inferences and
predictions on the fly.
I think it's also important to mention
that one of the main key points of their
paper is that self representation, so
beliefs about how beliefs about the self
can facilitate interpersonal minimization
of surprise.
So even what I think about me and how I
represent that, while communicating, will
facilitate the other person's optimal
decision making at that moment, maybe by
providing the right kind of information
that they need to optimize.
Okay, so to the next two interesting
papers, ideas Worth spreading and an
active inference model of collective
intelligence.
So the key idea, I think, for both of
these papers is the emergence of group
behaviors from local interactions.
For Caston Hess, this is the global group
behaviors cultural transmission or
transmission of beliefs and norms.
And they describe this process as the
mutual achievement of actively inferring
agents through communication.
And theory of mind is one of the many
mechanisms that facilitate this process
of achievement.
So that's the link.
And they show that the spread of certain
kinds of beliefs through a group can be
modeled just by making agents interact in
diadic groups and stimuli.
Kaufman et al.
Show that you can create a system of free
energy minimizing agents with some
minimal properties of social intelligence,
, such as the ability to assess how self
similar another agent is to themselves,
the ability to infer another agent's
intentions, and the ability to align
their goals to another agent, more or
less.
And they show that if you put all of
these agents together in those diets,
they don't only minimize free energy on
the dietic scale, but they also minimize
free energy as a collective.
And thereby, this is a very simple model
of how adaptive behaviors, group adaptive
group behaviors, could emerge from agents
with very simple social abilities.
Okay, so now we get to thinking through
other minds, which is not technically a
proposal for theory of mind, but it's a
proposal for how social cognition shapes
inculturation more generally and what
kind of abilities agents need to
facilitate this kind of normation.
And I think it's a very interesting
proposal because I think it highlights an
important function of social behavior
more generally.
And you could even see it as a way to
redefine theory of mind as more of an
interactional concept than as an
individual level cognitive ability.
So, according to this proposal, thinking
through other minds is a property of
multiple interacting minimizing agents
and a process by which agents infer other
agents expectations.
And based on this, the authors propose a
definition of enculturation as a process
of learning social expectations through
the selective patterning of attention
that guides agents towards relevant
affordances within their social and
cultural niche.
I'm not sure if you're all familiar with
the concept of affordances but it was
quite hyped up a couple of years ago.
In general it is defined as relational
construct denoting possibilities for
action offered by an environment that are
code determined also by an agent's
interest, goals and abilities.
So I think that the standard example for
this is when you are thirsty, a glass of
water might appear as an affordance or
you might not consciously or might also
tend to it otherwise.
And cultural affordances in this sense
are epistemic affordances.
So affordances that give you some
epistemic value that have come to stand
out as reliable and relevant based on a
history of culture information they
encode.
And good examples for this are different
kinds of signs of traffic signs.
We learn what they mean from a young age
and we sort of inherited the symbolism of
the traffic signs and they guide our
intention towards points in traffic and
they regulate our behaviors.
So when you look at the complete proposal,
, it sketches how the regulation of
social behavior depends on the learning
of shared norms and expectations and also
how this connects to utilizing cultural
affordances and thinking through other
minds.
As this profits interactional processing,
in which agents learn to infer each other'
's expectations to optimize collective
behavior and decision making.
Okay, so from these interesting active
inference and broader proposals of fear
of mind we get to the issue of form.
Sophistication in active inference so
what is fear of mind?
Sophistication a short recap it's the
depth of reclusivity that can be utilized
for fear of mind of the form.
I think that they think that I think, and
it has been found that agents generally
use a reclusivity of between zero and
four and that humans, humans ability for
recursive belief reasoning is generally
limiting but in principle, formally this
could go on forever.
And one way to implement this kind of
sort of arbitrarily recursive belief
inference is proposed by Vada et al.
Uses a Bayesian model of sophisticated
theory of minds with Ktom agents and
provides simulations in which K tom
agents play against agents that are just
one level of recursivity under them.
And this model has been used for a lot of
interesting simulation experiments.
For example.
Devane Et Al Showed that in a trade based
analysis but with agents having a fixed
depth of theory of mind reclusivity there
is a specific distribution of agents with
level one tom and level two tom that
could provide an evolutionary advantage
compared to populations with larger
proportions of serotonin three tom agents.
.
So they look at the adaptive properties
of systems with different kinds of ratios
of theory of my sophistication.
And in another experiment, which is a
state based analysis for Joe et al.
Showed that if you use computational
phenotyping on autistic individuals, this
shows reduced sensitivity to task framing
and strategy switching within the game
that they'll be using and theoretical
line sophistication.
So these are just some interesting
applications for theoretical mind
sophistication.
And the promise of modeling theoretical
mind sophistication would be that you
could investigate how people flexibly
switch between different social
strategies while solving a social task.
And one of them would be to increase the
depth of fear of my sophistication or
decrease it depending also on what you
think about the other agent's.
Sophistication.
So what I've been working on at the
moment is an active inference model of
social prediction during the Matching
pennies game.
The matching pennies game is a game farm
economics with a very simple format.
There are two rules.
You have the guesser and the challenger.
The challenger hides a penny in one of
the two hands.
The guesser needs to guess which hand, if
the guesser is correct, they win, if the
guesser is wrong, be challenger wins.
This game has some logical equivalents.
One version of the game makes both of the
agents select heads or tails.
So the challenger selects heads or tails
and the getter guesses the tests or tails.
.
But both have the same formal structure.
And psychological experiments of subjects
performing this task have shown that
there is a strong social framing effect
in the Matching Pennies game.
So participants will behave and perform
differently depending on whether they're
seeing that they're playing against a
human agent versus an AI for example.
Additionally, a comparison of Ketone and
other computational strategies that were
fitted on experimental data of subjects
playing the game revealed that
participants seem to use fear of mind
when playing the game.
So there is a strong indication that
theory of mind use does play a role in
the Matching pennies game and that social
framing will influence the social
strategy that's being employed by the
players.
So this is the very simple zero sum
architecture for the Matching pennies
game.
And I included beliefs about self choices
as also kind of monetary self states
beliefs about other agents choices on
whether the agent thinks the opposing
agent has hidden the penny left or right.
.
And then the agent also tracks the war
dates.
Since the game in this setting is devised
in a way in which the agents both make an
observation simultaneously and then all
of the observations are revealed, this
set up made sense so just going to drink
a little water.
The outcome modalities or observations
that the agents have are its own choice
observations, the choice observations of
the opposite agent and the reward
observations and the possibility the
action space is very limited.
The seeker can choose to seek left or
right and the hider which is the same as
the challenger before, has the
possibility of hiding penny left or right
and the reward is uncontrollable since it
depends on both agents choices at the
same time.
Yeah.
So this is sort of a summary of the
architecture that I just described and
this is another visualization of this
setup.
And you can see here that if you look at
the likelihoods the reward mapping for
the seeker is just the opposite as for
the hider.
And I think that this simple setup is
very suited for studying fear of mind in
these kinds of simple competitive
interactions.
Okay, so if you wanted to study the use
of theoretical bind sophistication in the
matching penny scheme using active
inference, I ran into a couple of
challenges and one of them was how to
steer the problem of recurring s.
So how can we make a difference between
the focal agent and the other agents?
If we try to model the other agents
within one agent, especially if you want
to introduce or formalize desperate cave
reclusivity, you can't just make one
agent simulate the other agent simulating
their self.
There needs to be some kind of sort of
structure that distinguishes the self
inferential mechanism, a self learning
mechanism from what the agent focal agent
thinks the other agent is thinking and
seeing and doing.
And I think the gentleman with the bowler
hat by firster in 2003 is a good example
for this problem.
So the basic setting is that our world is
populated by beings like ourselves
experiencing themselves as a subject, as
the focal point of their world, with
their own thoughts and feelings.
And they all think that they're the one
and only subject.
But there can't all be.
So there needs to be sort of either an
outside focal point or one ultimate main
subject.
I think more practically, the questions
that arise from this example are how do
we distinguish between focal agents and
simulated agents and how can we simulate
other agents in a way that is
computationally efficient and maybe uses
the same kinds of resources that the
agent already has?
So I actually had a lab meeting at the
Theoretical Neurobiology Lab a while ago
and we were brainstorming about this
issue and one of the ideas that came up
was to use sophisticated inference for
period mind.
So in this case, an active inference
formulation of belief recursivity could
be used for modeling recursive period,
line.
Basically, serious planning using
predictions about the other agents into
account would consist of evaluating all
the kinds of hypothetical scenarios, all
kinds of counterfactuals on how your
actions might influence their beliefs and
their actions and so on and so on.
So this would be one road to go into.
But this would also mean that all these
counterfeituals would need to be
evaluated.
So I was thinking is there a sort of more
efficient way to sort of use these kinds
of either internal simulations or kind of
special evaluation?
And the current approach I'm working on,
which I'm also sort of still developing.
So I'm very much open to feedback and
comments on how this could work and
possible alternative approaches at this
point.
But the general idea would be to create a
partial internal simulation of the other
agent's control mechanism.
So taking the learning mechanism of an
active inference agent as sort of the
definition of what the focal agent is,
that is the agent that perceives and
learns and infers from the environment
and what the agent does when predicting
the observations of the other agent or
the predicting the other agent's behavior
is basically performing partial
simulation about what it thinks the other
agent preferences are and what it thinks
that the other agent strategy is, which
is encoded by the transition from state
to state.
And one of the potential ways in which
you could include reclusivity in this way
is that you pretend that you have control
over the other agent's actions and you
predict the other states.
You predict self states, you evaluate the
state action probabilities, choose the
most valuable action based on that
distribution, simulate the other states
that come forth and simulate the self
states that come forth.
And then you have a new and then this can
be used for the next round of action
selection by the other model.
So in this case, only the per preferences
and the agent specific transition
probabilities would be needed as sort of
information on the other agent.
And because you also want to include some
kind of learning about the other agent
strategies, one of the things you could
implement would be learning also the Bay
metrics.
So having sort of the specific having the
agents accumulate as evidence about these
state transitions over time to also
better predict the other agents potential
actions.
The basic principle would be to simulate
control from the perspective of the other
agents and the recusivity comes into play
when you simulate the other when you've
already simulated the others predicted
actions and predicted other states and
you've simulated your own actions as a
consequence of those simulated actions.
You can feed that back into the other
model to predict what they would do if
they thought that you were in the state
that you were in.
And I think that could be a way to
develop repressivity in a way that does
not need complete simulations of parallel
agents within the same system.
And of course there should be some kind
of temporal discounting subparameter that
discounts evidence based on the simulated
planning horizon that is defined by the K
number of steps.
So yeah, this is sort of a conceptual
outline of how you could implement
because the fear of mind using active
inference we haven't been able to perform
simulations using this yet, but we're
working on that and we're very much open
to discussions on this and technical
comments on how to improve on this
outline.
And one of sort of the open questions
that we are still thinking about is how
to make the agent effectively infer the
depth of reclusivity of the other agent
in.
A setting.
Yeah.
Special thanks to Guillaume Dumas, who
will also be there at a panel, I think,
in session two, who's supervising me
during this project.
Thanks to the PPSP labor, I'm doing my
internship to Rudy Said, who's also
working on a related project, the Pi MDP
team, for that great coding package that
I'm using, and for Kofristen for his
feedback and ideas on my previous
presentations.
Thank you very much for listening.
Cool.
Daniel: Great presentation.
Very comprehensive review of a lot of the
different theory of mind options out
there.
Well, if anyone has questions, they can
write it in live chat.
What do you want to explore?
Or can I ask a question or what would be
fun for you?
Nynke: I'm blinded by the light at this
point, so I can't easily read from my
screen.
So maybe it would be nice if you could
read out the questions that are the live
chat.
Sure.
Daniel: Oh, yeah, sure.
Well, first one part I found interesting,
you mentioned that people play
differently when they are playing a human
or when they believe that they're playing
a human.
So what is that like?
What is the difference in play when we
believe that we're playing another
person?
Nynke: If I look at the original paper,
there is one study on this, and then they
did the computational phenotyping study
using Ktom and alternative strategies,
and they showed that if you use the
social framing condition, that subjects
will more probably employ figure five
strategies compared to other simple
reward based strategies.
So maybe those strategies could better be
described using some kind of reward
learning mechanism.
What the difference in their overall sort
of trajectory of choices is, I don't know.
.
Daniel: Yeah.
A few themes then that you brought up
that came up earlier in the session.
So one was using Pymdp and sophisticated
inference, which Aspen Paul gave a
walkthrough on.
And this question about recursivity and
about the way in which you can on one
hand talk about abstractly like K
Recursivity, yet the biological system
doesn't implement that kind of a logic.
Could you maybe describe a little bit
again?
How does the structure that you laid out
for the generative model capture some of
those features of recursivity without
falling into the trap of just theory of
mind all the way down?
Nynke: Yes.
So my general idea was to simulate the
other agent's action prediction based on
learning about the transition
probabilities for what we think how the
other agents face transition.
And then if you've predicted what the
other agent would do, you can use that as
a prior for calculating action dependent
expected states.
And based on those evaluating those
expected states, you simulate your own
choice mechanism.
And I think in principle, you could use
this recursive simulation indefinitely.
But also, it's also devised in a way that
it uses the same kind of sort of just the
architecture of the focal agent.
So the other idea was to just use
internal simulations all the way down and
but that would be very cognitively
implausible and yeah, I think it's a very
good question, because why would you even
need to formalize belief?
reclusivity all the way down.
If in end effect, people only use tom
with a set sort of maximal depth and the
fact that we use fear of mind with a
maximum depth might also be sort of a
hint that he might also use a different
or what we do might also be described by
a different strategy.
So yeah, I'm not sure if that's an answer
to your question.
Daniel: Yeah, well when I saw this and
some of the other generative models you
mentioned maybe here like you pretend
like you can control the other person's
mind and that's kind of the fundamental
weaving of action into the inference
challenge and then that uses expected
free energy just like any other policy
selection.
So it's like pragmatic value would be
bringing that controllable state your
social partner's mind or beliefs bringing
them into alignment with your preferences
is pragmatic and then learning more about
them is epistemic.
And so then that might enable some theory
of mind like behavior where it's like
when you don't know enough to put the
squeeze on then you have a kind of open
ended learning and curiosity and question
driven theory of mind.
But then once one has enough to kind of
exploit rather than explore then without
necessarily even updating the model or
engaging any deeper recursivity or
strategic shifting you could get social
behavior that's oriented towards control
and pragmatic value rather than just like
learning and questioning.
Nynke: Yeah, I think you're very right.
The idea was also to enable the agent to
maybe first use strategies that are more
useful in gathering evidence about the
kinds of strategies that the other agent
is using before exploiting thing what you'
've learned about the other agent and.